while donald trump is keeping a low
profile joe biden is putting himself
front and center
this was an event to discuss the
affordable care act but the
president-elect took questions on other
topics and he had a message
to the man he'll replace and his refusal
to accept the result
i just think it's an embarrassment um
quite frankly uh the only thing that
how can i say this tactfully i think it
will not help the president's legacy
i think that i know from my discussions
with foreign leaders thus far that
they are hopeful that the united states
democratic institutions are viewed once
again as being strong and
endured and uh but i think at the end of
the day
uh you know it's all going to come to
fruition
on january 20th while foreign leaders
are calling joe biden to congratulate
him
trump's secretary of state america's top
diplomat has called the result
into question there will be a smooth
transition
to a second trump administration
right we're ready the world is watching
what's taking place
we're going to count all the votes when
the process is complete there'll be
electors selected
there's a process the constitution lays
it out pretty clearly
various government agencies and
departments it's been reported have been
ordered by the white house not to help
with the presidential transition
because in its view the result is still
in doubt
that hasn't stopped joe biden pushing
ahead with planning for day one
even without the immediate assistance of
the trump administration
and the leader of the republicans in the
senate says the delay
won't create problems i don't think
anything that's
occurred so far interrupts an ordinary
process of moving through the various
steps that i indicated
and allowing if there is a new
administration it to
work through the transition all of these
steps will be taken
at the appropriate time this election
has already seen a lot of legal
challenges
there might be another one coming as the
biden campaign considers going to court
to force donald trump's team to start
planning for a handover of power
alan fisher al jazeera washington